[Musique]
une semaine de vacances
des vacances au frais de la présidente
et du Champagney au frais par un coach
qui a mouillé plus que sa chemise
leur cinquième titre d'affilée sacrifie
de l'OL championne de France Montpellier
hier pluie et terrain synthétique la
première période manque de synthèse et
puis à la 60e le but de la victoire sur
un franc coup de pied de Sonia bombastor
Wendi renard s'élève plus haut que les
autres et Marc de la tête
ce carton plein parce que on a quand
même je crois que c'est 18 victoires
c'est même impressionnant c'est les
filles ont été chercher dans leur
ressources cette victoire surtout sur la
deuxième mi-temps on a été costaud bon
c'est ils ont été encore très très
grandes premier titre de champion de
France pour Patrice Clerc un sacre qui a
lieu chez lui face à son ancienne équipe
de Montpellier les filles en sont alors
18e rencontre emporté 5 matchs en 14
jours petit à petit elles avancent entre
dans la danse vers le triple et gagnant
tant mieux si ce qu'on voulait puis on
avance on prend un match après le match
et puis on avance on a envie de
d'exploser les records donc après on se
donne tout le temps à fond les matchs
maintenant on va bien on a deux jours de
repos on va bien se reposer du repos
avant d'attaquer Juvisy la semaine
prochaine pour les quarts de finale du
Challenge de France mais ce qu'elles ont
en tête c'est la Ligue des Champions les
demi-finales face à Arsenal elles se
sont d'ores et déjà donné rendez-vous à
Craven Cottage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]